Jack: 看缺啥就行
Jack: See what's missing.
Shure: 我怎么老找不到
Shure: Why can't I find it?
Shure: 那什么你
Shure: So, you...
Jack: 你就之前在开始之前跑那个
Jack: Just run that one you ran before we started.
Nicous: 哎我没有啊
Nicous: Hey, I don't have it.
Nicous: 就我们课堂我们那个
Nicous: In our class, we...
Jack: contrast
Jack: Contrast.
Nicous: 然后就是Outlook然后他全都直接有
Nicous: And then Outlook, it has everything directly.
Shure: 等一下
Shure: Wait a minute.
Jack: 怎么怎么没有interview
Jack: How come there's no interview?
Jack: 坏
Jack: Broken.
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh my god.
Jack: 哎我这是这是petrol吗
Jack: Hey, is this petrol?
Shure: 这是petrol对
Shure: This is petrol, yes.
Jack: 这坏了不会
Jack: This broken, can't be.
Jack: 上一次用petrol还是大二
Jack: Last time I used petrol was sophomore year.
Jake:1500
Jake: 1500.
Jake:2024
Jake: 2024.
Shure: 我早开了
Shure: I opened it a long time ago.
Jack: 你用petrol吗
Jack: Do you use petrol?
Jack: 你给他配一下petrol
Jack: Configure petrol for him.
Nicous: petrol太好配了啊
Nicous: Petrol is so easy to configure.
Shure: 你看
Shure: Look
Shure: 来来来他就会蹦出来这个
Shure: Come, come, it will just pop up here
Choiszt: 傻瓜教学
Choiszt: Dummy guide
Shure: 不我环境都没好呢
Shure: No, my environment isn't set up yet
Nicous: 啊啊我错了哥
Nicous: Ah, ah, my bad, bro
Shure: yes然后他会给我报这个
Shure: Yes, and then it will report this to me
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: trouble shooting some Conta package install啦啦啦
Shure: Trouble shooting some Conta package install, la la la
Shure: for example
Shure: For example
Jack: 不你你现在create一个新环境
Jack: No, now you create a new environment
Shure: 啊可以
Shure: Ah, okay
Jack: 对你create
Jack: Yes, you create it
Jack: 就是缺什么装什么
Jack: Install whatever you need
Jack: 绝对最快
Jack: It’s absolutely the fastest
Jack: 相信我绝对最快
Jack: Trust me, it's the fastest
Shure: 对OK
Shure: Yes, OK
Jack: 这这你缺什么装什么
Jack: Whatever you need, just install it
Jack: 今天你回来必给你跑起来
Jack: By the time you come back today, it will be running
Jack: 哈哈这这这坐着三个
Jack: Haha, there are three people here
Shure: 这坐着三个天天配环境的人
Shure: Three people who set up environments every day
Jack: 必给你跑起来
Jack: It will definitely run
Shure: 我相信你们的
Shure: I trust you guys
Jack: 你就随便可以
Jack: You can just
Jack: 你看看你拍摄的版本也行
Jack: You can check the version you shot
Jack: 3:10一般都能用
Jack: 3:10 usually works
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one
Shure: 就跟我那个本地那个一模一样的
Shure: It's exactly the same as my local one
Shure: 这都是不是
Shure: These are not
Nicous: 不是
Nicous: No
Nicous: 他这玩意只给你下那种正正版的软件
Nicous: It only downloads genuine software for you
Nicous: 然后他是那种
Nicous: And then it is
Choiszt: 但是你没有激活码
Choiszt: But you don't have an activation code
Nicous: 对啊而且
Nicous: Yeah, and
Nicous: 他问有没有那个微软的365
Nicous: It asks if you have Microsoft 365
Jake:微软的链接
Jake: Microsoft link
Jake:我也没有码
Jake: I don't have the code either
Jack: 我有码我有账号
Jack: I have the code, I have the account
Jack: 我可以一会
Jack: I can later
Jack: 一会今天晚
Jack: Later tonight
Jack: 上回来发给你
Jack: I'll send it to you
Choiszt: 你发我就行
Choiszt: Just send it to me.
Nicous: 你也可以
Nicous: You can too.
Nicous: 你也我也我也我也我也
Nicous: You can, I can, I can, I can, I can.
Nicous: 快毕业了不
Nicous: Are you graduating soon?
Choiszt: 你那个码是哪来的
Choiszt: Where did you get that code?
Jack: 腾讯呗哈哈哈
Jack: From Tencent, haha.
Nicous: 发我们用用
Nicous: Send it to us to use.
Choiszt: 能用吗
Choiszt: Can we use it?
Choiszt: 找你买一条
Choiszt: I'll buy one from you.
Jack: 看不到他就是一个激活账号
Jack: You can't see it, it's just an activation account.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Choiszt: 真可以用吗
Choiszt: Can we really use it?
Jake:我们准备买东西
Jake: We are preparing to buy stuff.
Jake:我们要买什么呢
Jake: What do we need to buy?
Jake:我们还要补一些
Jake: We still need to get some more.
Nicous: 我们的world就是
Nicous: Our world is just...
Jake:还有谁要补
Jake: Does anyone else need to get something?
Jake:你有要补的东西吗
Jake: Do you need anything?
Jake:你要补酒吗
Jake: Do you need more wine?
Shure: 补点
Shure: A little more.
Jake:补点
Jake: A little more.
Jake:你还要补啥
Jake: What else do you need?
Jack: 你如果没激活你那啥也打不了
Jack: If you don't activate it, you can't do anything.
Shure: 我酒冰饮料
Shure: Wine, cold drinks.
Jake:你琢磨琢磨
Jake: Think it over.
Shure: 就饮品上补齐就行
Shure: Just restock the drinks.
其他人：然后他这个都是同同步的所以
Others: And everything here is synchronized, so...
Jake:路亚要补点什么吗
Jake: Luyar, do you need to restock anything?
Jake:补什么
Jake: What to restock?
Jake:补货
Jake: Restock.
Jake:我们要买东西的话要补什么货吗
Jake: If we are going to buy stuff, what do we need to restock?
Jake:雨轩要补货吗
Jake: Yuxuan, do you need to restock?
Katrina: 我思考一下
Katrina: I'll think about it.
Lucia: 如果有蓝色系的明信片的话或者
Lucia: If there are any blue-themed postcards or...
Shure: 怎么那个
Shure: How about that...
Shure: 把那个这个的那个
Shure: Turn that thing into that...
Shure: 变成那个康纳的那个环境来着
Shure: Change it into Connor's environment.
Lucia: 我觉得我那个照片
Lucia: I think my photo...
Lucia: 墙上可能需要戳两个
Lucia: Might need a couple of pins on the wall.
Lucia: 但是当时好像买了也来不及
Lucia: But at that time, it might have been too late to buy them.
Lucia: 太不太来得及到
Lucia: It's almost too late.
Jake:这玩意要收起来哦
Jake: We need to put this away.
Jake:可以收
Jake: We can store it.
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶是不是要买
Katrina: Should we buy some Wangzai milk?
Lucia: 美文纸我买了
Lucia: I bought the pretty paper.
Lucia: 他今天应该到了
Lucia: It should arrive today.
Lucia: 我看看啊
Lucia: Let me check.
Katrina: 那那旺仔牛奶是不是要外送
Katrina: Should we get the Wangzai milk delivered?
Katrina: 要大概几瓶
Katrina: How many bottles do we need?
Katrina: 那就买那种一板行不行
Katrina: How about we buy a whole pack?
Jake:我们来记个小本本
Jake: Let's note it down.
Shure: 行了
Shure: Got it.
Nicous: 可是他妈才创
Nicous: But his mom just created it.
Nicous: 然后一个没创进去啊
Nicous: And it didn't go through.
Katrina: 黑板可以拿出来了
Katrina: The blackboard can be brought out now.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Katrina: 户外教学
Katrina: Outdoor teaching.
Jack: 今天今天晚上教我配Alab的机器
Jack: Tonight, teach me how to set up the Alab machine.
Choiszt: 你要配那个
Choiszt: You want to set that up?
Choiszt: 干啥
Choiszt: For what?
Jack: 干活再不干活就要干死我
Jack: If I don't work, I'm going to die from not working.
Jack: 再不干活我就可以不干了
Jack: If I don't work, I might as well quit.
Jake:来个人抬黑板
Jake: Someone help carry the blackboard.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Nicous: 不是你每次每次
Nicous: Every time, every time.
Nicous: 叼的是同一个吧
Nicous: It's the same one, right?
Choiszt: 可能吧
Choiszt: Maybe.
Lucia: 每次叼的是同一个
Lucia: Every time, it's the same one.
Nicous: 别他妈这一盒他妈全部给叼一个
Nicous: Don't take the whole box, just take one.
Choiszt: 那就给我得了
Choiszt: Then just give it to me.
Choiszt: 我来跟别人social
Choiszt: I'll socialize with others.
Choiszt: social通行
Choiszt: Socializing access.
Nicous: 这一盒给你
Nicous: Here, take the box.
Nicous: 八个
Nicous: Eight of them.
Nicous: 转我20块钱就行
Nicous: Just transfer me 20 yuan.
Choiszt: 20根是吧嗯
Choiszt: 20 sticks, right? Hmm.
Choiszt: 我觉得可以
Choiszt: I think it's fine.
Choiszt: 买点槟榔给人送
Choiszt: Buy some betel nuts to give away.
Nicous: 你是真傻逼吧
Nicous: Are you really that dumb?
Nicous: 你是想害人
Nicous: Are you trying to hurt people?
Choiszt: 不是那你
Choiszt: No, then you
Choiszt: 那你说能买啥
Choiszt: Then what do you think we can buy?
Nicous: 巧克力吧
Nicous: Chocolate, maybe?
Jake:放边上吧
Jake: Just put it aside.
Jake:放放那个最左边
Jake: Put it on the far left.
Choiszt: 真晒呀
Choiszt: It's really sunny.
Jake:黄是怎么打的
Jake: How did you beat Yellow?
Choiszt: QA是什么
Choiszt: What is QA?
Katrina: 就是那是我写的and
Katrina: That's what I wrote and
Katrina: 哈哈哈q and a我不太会画那个符号
Katrina: Hahaha Q and A, I can't really draw that symbol.
Katrina: 就是地球世界地球日的那个问答
Katrina: It's the Q&A for Earth Day.
Choiszt: 那还要准备问题吗
Choiszt: So do we need to prepare questions?
Jake:对要准备问题
Jake: Yes, we need to prepare questions.
Katrina: 哎写一下吧
Katrina: Hey, write it down.
Choiszt: 我们GBT准备开
Choiszt: We're preparing for GBT.
Jake:我们中午准备了一些问题
Jake: We prepared some questions at noon.
Jake:比如说比如说啥来着
Jake: Like, for example, what was it?
Katrina: 中午那确实是问题吗
Katrina: Were those really questions at noon?
Lucia: 中午那不是问题
Lucia: Those weren't questions at noon.
Lucia: 那只是大家讲的
Lucia: Those were just discussions.
Nicous: 你有BIOS了吗
Nicous: Do you have the BIOS?
Jake:不孕不育会遗传吧
Jake: Infertility can be hereditary, right?
Shure: 我一个一个insolent了
Shure: I insolent one by one.
Jack: 你还在上面装酷拉拽是吧
Jack: Are you still acting all cool up there?
Shure: 算了我就一步一步来了
Shure: Forget it, I'll just take it step by step.
Jack: 健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jack: Can digestive tablets make you full?
Jack: 能绝对可以
Jack: They definitely can.
Jack: 它含糖耶
Jack: They contain sugar.
Lucia: 大家都很有逻辑的在回答一些问题
Lucia: Everyone is logically answering some questions.
Jake:可多了
Jake: Quite a lot.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我们现在要干嘛来着
Shure: What are we doing now?
Jake:我们现在盘算盘算要买啥
Jake: We're figuring out what to buy.
Nicous: 然后你们盘算吧
Nicous: Then you guys figure it out.
Nicous: 我继续搞毕了
Nicous: I'll continue with the BIOS.
Jake:你去干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:搞毕哦
Jake: The BIOS.
Jake:你在这搞毕吧
Jake: Do it here.
Shure: 对你在这搞
Shure: Yeah, do it here.
Jack: 我不要好奇
Jack: I don't want to be curious.
Jack: 你上你上什么网站
Jack: Which website are you visiting?
Nicous: 但是你看他他说的
Nicous: But look, he said...
Nicous: 你每次创下要0.5
Nicous: Every time you create, it costs 0.5.
Nicous: SOL他这傻逼狙击吧
Nicous: SOL, that idiot sniper.
Jack: 这个好像是有点像那种低赛号
Jack: This seems like a low-ranked account.
Nicous: 帮你创好哦
Nicous: I'll create it for you.
Nicous: 这也是一种情况
Nicous: This is also a situation.
Choiszt: 就你你创个平台上
Choiszt: You, you create a platform.
Katrina: 美文纸买了是吧
Katrina: Did you buy the beautiful paper?
Tasha: 美文纸买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the beautiful paper?
Choiszt: 为什么要虚拟
Choiszt: Why virtual...
Choiszt: 货币
Choiszt: Currency?
Lucia: 应该到了
Lucia: It should have arrived.
Lucia: 我今天收到他
Lucia: I received it today.
Jake:黑板擦在哪
Jake: Where's the blackboard eraser?
Lucia: 什么这也是奇葩问题吗难道
Lucia: What, is this a weird question too?
Jack: 我们花钱就0.0000000001美分一个币
Jack: We spend just 0.0000000001 cents per coin.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha
Jack: 货币一般等价
Jack: General equivalent of currency.
Katrina: 哦我们等会出去吗要
Katrina: Oh, are we going out later?
Choiszt: 这还真有人
Choiszt: There's actually someone...
Tasha: 对啊我们等会要出去
Tasha: Yeah, we're going out later.
Katrina: 我们等会要出去买啊
Katrina: We're going out to buy stuff later.
Jake:出去吧
Jake: Let's go out.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:啊也可以不出
Jake: Or we don't have to.
Jake:可以派一波人出去买啊
Jake: We can send a group of people to buy.
Shure: 抽嗯
Shure: Draw, hmm.
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 完了我他妈的
Shure: I'm screwed.
Jake:最近天太好了
Jake: The weather's been too good lately.
Jack: http error g
Jack: HTTP error, g.
Jake:http error没网
Jake: HTTP error, no internet.
Jake:服务器没网
Jake: The server's down.
Jack: 不他本地没网
Jack: No, it's his local connection.
Shure: 不是这是服务器的啊
Shure: No, it's the server's issue.
Jack: 这服务器的啊
Jack: It's the server's issue.
Jake:没钱了
Jake: We're out of funds.
Shure: 怎么可能
Shure: How is that possible?
Shure: 我今天早上刚给他充100
Shure: I just topped it up with 100 this morning.
Choiszt: 我来看看
Choiszt: Let me take a look.
Shure: 什么叫export
Jack: 就你没开proxy吧
Jack: Maybe you didn't enable the proxy?
Shure: 嗯等会等会
Shure: Hmm, wait a minute.
Choiszt: 哎这不这可以吗
Choiszt: Hey, isn't this okay?
Nicous: 这不能装吗
Nicous: Can't this be installed?
Jack: 下这么快呀
Jack: Downloading so fast?
Shure: 不可能啊
Shure: Impossible.
Choiszt: 他有备份吗
Choiszt: Is there a backup?
Jack: 一秒跑90%
Jack: 90% in a second.
Shure: 这5005百k每秒的
Shure: It's 500k per second.
Shure: 不可能这绝逼是假的这个东西
Shure: No way, this must be fake.
Shure: 什么叫clash
Shure: What does clash mean?
Shure: cash是什么意思
Shure: What does cache mean?
Nicous: 就你以前存过
Nicous: Like you saved it before.
Lucia: CHE那个单词吗
Lucia: The word CHE?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 原来那个文件夹是这个意思
Lucia: Oh, so that's what that folder means.
Jack: cash
Jack: Cache.
Shure: 应该是可以的
Shure: It should be possible.
Lucia: 整理自己的那个啥系统的时候
Lucia: When you were organizing your system.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈对没联网
Choiszt: Hahaha, yeah, not connected to the internet.
Nicous: 哈哈哈可他可他失败掉了
Nicous: Hahaha, but he failed.
Nicous: 神经病啊
Nicous: Crazy.
Nicous: 应该是有网
Nicous: There should be internet.
Shure: 有网我肯定不
Shure: If there's internet, I definitely...
Choiszt: 你可能
Choiszt: You might...
Shure: 我墙翻了
Shure: I did bypass it.
Shure: clash开着呢
Shure: Clash is running.
Lucia: 西柚的比葡萄的好喝一点
Lucia: Grapefruit juice is better than grape juice.
Lucia: 因为我们上次买的是朗姆
Lucia: Because last time we bought rum.
Lucia: 就是橙汁
Lucia: Just orange juice.
Lucia: 其实应该兑龙舌兰的
Lucia: It should actually be mixed with tequila.
Katrina: 哦我们现在有拿酒
Katrina: Oh, we're having alcohol now.
Katrina: 那要不要再买一瓶气泡酒
Katrina: Should we buy another bottle of sparkling wine?
Lucia: 气泡酒还有一瓶
Lucia: We still have a bottle of sparkling wine.
Jack: 买那个旺仔牛奶
Jack: Buy that Wangzai milk.
Nicous: 旺仔牛奶配百利甜
Lucia: 你要甜死我哈哈哈
Lucia: You're gonna sweeten me to death, hahaha.
Choiszt: 好像还是能下的
Choiszt: I think I can still drink this.
Jack: 红石榴糖浆龙舌兰日出
Jack: Pomegranate syrup Tequila Sunrise.
Katrina: 咱咱还有什么酒来着
Katrina: What other drinks do we have?
Katrina: 那一瓶是什么呀
Katrina: What's that bottle?
Katrina: 还有什么酒
Katrina: Any other drinks?
Shure: 咱这朗姆啊
Shure: We have rum here.
Katrina: 气泡气泡的有一瓶
Katrina: There's a bottle of something sparkling.
Shure: 汽个气气泡的
Shure: Something sparkling.
Katrina: 然后还有呢
Katrina: And what else?
Katrina: 还有就是朗姆的半瓶
Katrina: We have half a bottle of rum.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 一个底了
Shure: Almost done.
Shure: 你可以你是不是一会不去对吧
Shure: Are you not going later, right?
Nicous: 干嘛
Nicous: What?
Shure: 买东西的话
Shure: If you're buying stuff...
Nicous: 我去我去
Nicous: I'll go, I'll go.
Shure: 你别去了
Shure: You don't need to go.
Shure: 你帮我把
Shure: Help me...
Nicous: 我不帮你搞
Nicous: I won't help you.
Shure: 你在这帮我搞环境吧
Shure: Help me set up here.
Nicous: 我不如去
Nicous: I'd rather go.
Shure: 不是你就按照他这一步一步来就行
Shure: Just follow his steps, it's fine.
Shure: 我当时就按照这一步一步来的
Shure: I followed these steps back then.
Lucia: 因为感觉不是太会踩雷
Lucia: Because it feels like I won't make mistakes.
Jake:这还是昨天的
Jake: This is still from yesterday.
Jake:那天的声明
Jake: The statement from that day.
Lucia: 百利甜是一种甜酒
Lucia: Baileys is a type of sweet liqueur.
Jack: 我靠还买了香槟吗
Jack: Did we actually buy champagne?
Shure: 也不是香槟吧
Shure: It's not champagne.
Shure: 是气泡酒
Shure: It's sparkling wine.
Katrina: 香槟真的假的
Katrina: Champagne, really?
Shure: 那个就行那个就行
Shure: That one is fine.
Shure: 嗯能崩一下就就就可以了
Shure: Yeah, as long as it pops, it's good.
Katrina: 北冰洋还要买吗
Katrina: Do we need more Arctic Ocean?
Katrina: 哦可乐没了
Katrina: Oh, we're out of Coke.
Jack: 哎刚我看上面不是BM吗
Jack: Hey, wasn't there BM on top?
Katrina: 茶是什么
Katrina: What's hemp tea?
Jack: 就是上一个
Jack: Google上显示BM啊
Jack: Google shows BM, huh?
Tasha: 直接叫茶吗
Jake:嗯可以没问题没问题
Jake: Yeah, that's fine, no problem.
Katrina: 哪个叫什么是茶
Shure: 哎呦我吐了呀
Shure: Oh man, I'm gonna throw up.
Katrina: 什么维他茶
Katrina: What about Vita tea?
Katrina: 哦维他写了哈哈
Katrina: Oh, Vita wrote it, haha.
Lucia: 反正在我们的目标关注地区
Lucia: Anyway, in our target areas...
Lucia: 这玩意也是合法的是吗
Lucia: This thing is legal too, right?
Lucia: 我刚才这句话要不要删掉了
Lucia: Should I delete what I just said?
Shure: 不合法新加坡不合法
Shure: It's illegal. It's illegal in Singapore.
Jack: 我们还是希望
Jack: We still hope...
Jack: 中国的研究者们也可以用一下
Jack: That researchers in China can also use it.
Nicous: 但是我听人家网络上的事
Nicous: But I heard online...
Tasha: 蓝莓是不是没拆
Tasha: Haven't the blueberries been opened?
Katrina: 蓝莓吃掉了
Katrina: The blueberries were eaten.
Katrina: 什么时候买的
Katrina: When did we buy them?
Tasha: 什么时候吃掉的
Tasha: When did you eat them?
Tasha: 为什么没带我
Tasha: Why didn't you bring me?
Katrina: 洗了那天不知道什么时候洗
Katrina: They were washed, but I don't know when.
Katrina: 蓝莓草莓
Katrina: Blueberries and strawberries.
Jake:今天带今天带
Jake: I'll bring them today.
Tasha: 那就买草莓和蓝莓还有
Tasha: Then let's buy strawberries, blueberries, and...
Jake:哎全遮住了
Jake: Oh, it's all covered.
Jack: 你已经熟练的使用度假工具
Jack: You've become proficient with the vacation tools.
Katrina: 你喜欢吃榴莲是不
Katrina: Do you like to eat durian?
Jake:可以继续独家
Jake: You can continue exclusively.
Lucia: 哎我们之前买那盒榴莲吃完了吗
Lucia: Hey, did we finish that box of durians we bought before?
Shure: 不行又htttp error了
Shure: No, it's giving me an HTTP error again.
Shure: 我真的吐了呀
Shure: I'm really gonna throw up.
Jake:吃了吃了
Jake: We ate it, we ate it.
Tasha: 你看他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: Look, he secretly ate it.
Shure: 猫也挂着呢
Shure: The cat's still hanging around.
Shure: 我给你开global行不
Shure: Can I open global for you?
Shure: 为什么
Shure: Why?
Jake:哎这边有电话
Jake: Oh, there's a phone call.
Jake:有个上海的电话
Jake: A call from Shanghai.
Shure: twinmod我都开了
Shure: I already opened twinmod.
Shure: 上海人
Shure: Someone from Shanghai.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 那明天就是那个串要买吗
Katrina: So, should we buy those skewers tomorrow?
Katrina: 烤吗
Katrina: Grill them?
Katrina: 那就烤点串
Katrina: Then let's grill some skewers.
Katrina: 然后那个炭啊什么的都有了是吧
Katrina: And we have the charcoal and everything, right?
Shure: 炭没有
Shure: We don't have charcoal.
Shure: 我意思就是烧烤店了
Shure: I mean, let's get it from the BBQ place.
Jack: 从烧烤店买点熟的炭
Jack: Buy some ready-made charcoal from the BBQ place.
Jake:买点炭灰
Jake: Buy some charcoal ashes.
Lucia: 是不是又是一个弱智吧问题哈哈哈
Lucia: Is this another silly question? Hahaha 社会问题
Jake:明天要是这天气就太阳能好
Jake: If the weather is like this tomorrow, solar power would be good.
Katrina: 还还有那个如果说要唱歌的话
Katrina: And also, if we want to sing...
Katrina: 你音响能接话筒吗
Katrina: Can your speakers connect to a microphone?
Katrina: 有话筒吗
Katrina: Do you have a microphone?
Shure: 没有话筒
Shure: No microphone.
Jake:没有话筒怎么搞
Jake: How can we do it without a microphone?
Shure: 买话筒
Shure: Buy a microphone.
Nicous: 9块9 话筒
Nicous: 9.99 for a microphone.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Shure: 那不至于
Shure: That's not possible.
Shure: 一大概一话筒就100多块钱搞一个要不
Shure: A decent microphone would cost over 100 bucks. Should we get one?
Tasha: 租一个吧
Tasha: Let's rent one.
Shure: 次日达
Shure: Next-day delivery.
Tasha: 现在买还来得及吗
Tasha: Is it still possible to buy one now?
Shure: 费劲
Shure: It's a hassle.
Alice:明天天气比今天再热一点
Alice: Tomorrow's weather will be hotter than today.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Tasha: 怎么要买空调吗
Tasha: Are we buying an air conditioner?
Shure: 今天晚上
Shure: Tonight...
Shure: 你们回北邮吧
Shure: You guys head back to Beiyou.
其他人：烤肉用的超大
Others: The grill is huge.
Shure: 你们回北邮吧
Shure: You guys head back to Beiyou.
Shure: 我说你们
Shure: I'm saying you guys...
Tasha: 在呢
Tasha: Here we are.
Jake:北邮能带东西回来
Jake: Can you bring stuff back from Beiyou?
Shure: 对北邮能
Shure: Yes, Beiyou can.
Shure: 能带个麦克风回来
Shure: Can bring back a microphone.
Jake:那北邮会有别的人来吗
Jake: Will anyone else come from Beiyou?
Tasha: 不要了
Tasha: No need.
Shure: 哦也有哎
Shure: Oh, there are.
Shure: 啊对啊啊对啊
Shure: Oh, yes, there are.
Shure: 我靠我怎么没想到
Shure: Damn, why didn't I think of that?
Nicous: 明天是不是去学校
Nicous: Are we going to school tomorrow?
Nicous: 把你那个麦麦麦带来了
Nicous: Bring that mic of yours.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 今天今天买酒还买朗姆吗
Lucia: Are we buying rum today?
Katrina: 换那就换呗
Katrina: Let's switch it up then.
Lucia: 那就换龙舌兰呗
Lucia: Let's get tequila instead.
Lucia: 就是大家可以尝尝不同的口味吗
Lucia: So everyone can try different flavors.
Shure: 好对
Shure: Yeah, sure.
Katrina: 什么话筒
Katrina: What mic?
Katrina: 有是吗
Katrina: Do you have one?
Shure: 话筒北邮有
Shure: The mic is at Beiyou.
Shure: 有他们来的时候给我取了就行
Shure: They can bring it to me when they come.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What thing?
Shure: 推波波
Shure: Push the bubble.
Lucia: 我还以为是小提琴
Lucia: I thought it was a violin.
Nicous: 不是爱好
Nicous: It's not a hobby.
Shure: 还很可爱
Shure: It's quite cute.
Nicous: 就不是很像推波波
Nicous: It doesn't look like a push bubble.
Jake:你们都很能打的
Jake: You guys are really good at this.
Nicous: 没有跟他打打0:7
Nicous: I lost to him 0:7.
Shure: 我被称为北邮丁俊晖知道吗
Shure: I'm known as Beiyou Ding Junhui, you know?
Shure: 听说你叫北邮奥沙利文
Shure: I heard you're called Beiyou O'Sullivan.
Jake:我们一辆车能抓几个人
Jake: How many people can we fit in one car?
Shure: 如果是6个人去的话就可以
Shure: If there are six people, it should be fine.
Shure: 有个人能留在这帮我配环境
Shure: Someone can stay here to help me set up.
Jake:哈哈哈要不然就是你吧
Jake: Haha, why don't you stay then?
Jack: 对那你可以在这配环境
Jack: Yeah, you can stay and set up.
Jack: 不是你先搞一个贝斯
Jack: First, you need to set up the bass.
Jack: 你贝斯如果搞好剩下就只等
Jack: Once the bass is set up, the rest will be easy.
Jack: 你可以把开创式装起来就走
Jack: You can set up the initial installation and then go.
Jack: 回来就装好
Jack: Finish it when you come back.
Shure: 他现在自己在这装呢
Shure: He's setting it up by himself now.
Shure: 我可以再开一个命令行一起装吗
Shure: Can I open another command line to set it up together?
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 那这个他5下载速度是500KM秒
Shure: His download speed is 500KM per second.
Nicous: 那当你刷新还挺好吧
Nicous: That's pretty good when you refresh.
Shure: 我估计差不多
Shure: I think so too.
Shure: 回来他能装好都不错了这东西
Shure: It's good enough if he can finish the setup.
Jake:行啊走吧走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Shure: 咱们全全员都去是吧
Shure: Are we all going?
Jake:全员都去
Jake: Everyone's going.
Jake:还是再打一辆吧
Jake: Maybe we should get another taxi.
Jake:或者
Jake: Or...
Alice:我在家吧
Alice: I'll stay home.
Alice:我在家等着那个快递
Alice: I'll wait for the delivery at home.
Jake:紫堂不来了
Jake: Zitang isn't coming.
Jake:行那
Jake: Alright then.
Jack: 56788个人
Jack: 56,788 people.
Tasha: 12341234
Tasha: 12,341,234.
Nicous: 对的一个人
Nicous: Right, one person.
Nicous: 四个一个人五个
Nicous: Four people, one person, five.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:打车去哪啊
Jake: Take a taxi to where?
Jack: wherewherewhere
Jack: where where where?
Jake:我们别去
Jake: Let's not go there.
Jake:我们换一家超市
Jake: Let's go to a different supermarket.
Shure: 那你们有山姆会员吗
Shure: Do you guys have a Sam's Club membership?
Jack: 建义那有
Jack: Jianyi has one.
Jack: 通州区万达
Jack: Tongzhou Wanda.
Jake:去万达是吧
Jake: Go to Wanda, right?
Jack: 对稍微远一点
Jack: Yeah, it's a bit far.
Jack: 好像有通州区万达
Jack: I think there's one at Tongzhou Wanda.
Nicous: 万达也近
Nicous: Wanda is close too.
Lucia: 哦那个在通州北苑呢
Lucia: Oh, that one's at Tongzhou Beiyuan.
Jack: 反正我好像上次看到了
Jack: Anyway, I think I saw it last time.
Shure: 只要有超市的地方要去
Shure: As long as there's a supermarket, we'll go.
Lucia: 超市
Lucia: Supermarket.
Jake:超市儿
Jake: Supermarket.
Jack: 超市
Jack: Supermarket.
Choiszt: 那就万达呗
Choiszt: Then it's Wanda.
Choiszt: 然后卧槽
Choiszt: And then, whoa.
Choiszt: 7公里
Choiszt: 7 kilometers.
Jack: 7公里开车20多分钟吧
Jack: 7 kilometers, about 20 minutes driving.
Shure: 他是卡了吗
Shure: Is it stuck?
Shure: 他怎么不动弹呢
Shure: Why isn't it moving?
Jake:万达超市是什么超市
Jake: What kind of supermarket is Wanda?
Shure: 永辉吧
Shure: Yonghui, I think.
Jake:永辉
Jake: Yonghui.
Jack: 肯定很大
Jack: It must be huge.
Jake:可以可以那就去永辉
Jake: Okay, okay, then let's go to Yonghui.
Choiszt: 半个小时
Choiszt: Half an hour.
Choiszt: 我看看还有没有
Choiszt: Let me see if there's any left.
Shure: 你会你会配环境吗
Shure: Can you match the environment?
Jake:没买
Jake: Didn't buy it.
Jake:没设计出来
Jake: Didn't design it.
Shure: 他这有一个完完整的教程
Shure: He has a complete tutorial.
Shure: 你就按着他来就行
Shure: Just follow his instructions.
Choiszt: 要收谁米
Choiszt: Who are we charging?
Shure: 这个可能要装很久
Shure: This might take a long time to install.
Shure: 然后他他现在卡在这了
Shure: Now he's stuck here.
Shure: 他如果erro的话你就按下上键
Shure: If it errors out, just press the up key.
Shure: 然后你再按下回车
Shure: Then press enter.
Shure: 哎算了我手机控制吧
Shure: Never mind, I'll control it with my phone.
Shure: 我手机控制吧
Shure: I'll control it with my phone.
Jack: 你还可以这么牛逼
Jack: You can do that? Impressive.
Nicous: 卧槽这个我真崩不住了
Nicous: Damn, I really can't handle this.
Jack: 手机控电脑
Jack: Controlling the computer with your phone?
Jake:万达是吧
Jake: Wanda, right?
Choiszt: 哎这我附近有个物美
Choiszt: Hey, there's a Wumart nearby.
Shure: 哦我直接把他一直带着不就得了吗
Shure: Oh, should I just take him along?
Jake:物美很小
Jake: Wumart is small.
Jack: 建议万达
Jack: I suggest Wanda.
Choiszt: 没有看这外边看的还是挺大的
Choiszt: No, from the outside, it looks pretty big.
Shure: 没有我是
Shure: No, I...
Shure: 套了一个虚拟机
Shure: Set up a virtual machine.
Shure: 又套了一个虚拟机啥
Shure: Then set up another virtual machine.
Shure: 就是我用那个向日葵
Shure: I'm using Sunflower.
Shure: 先挂着我的那个Windows电脑
Shure: First, I connect to my Windows computer.
Shure: 然后再用Windows电脑挂着我那个
Shure: Then use my Windows computer to connect to my...
Shure: 腾讯云的
Shure: Tencent Cloud...
Shure: 那个服务器
Shure: Server.
Shure: 还行他真没有什么延时
Shure: It's fine, there's no latency.
Shure: 他都是在北京你知道吧
Shure: It's all in Beijing, you know.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 到底是永辉还是物美
Shure: So is it Yonghui or Wumart?
Lucia: 哎我觉得可以
Lucia: Hey, I think it's okay.
Shure: 你说你有点难
Shure: You think it's a bit hard.
Katrina: 反正是杨老板报销的
Katrina: Anyway, Jake is reimbursing.
Jake:你电脑放外边真的不会被
Jake: Your computer outside really won't get
Shure: 他晒不到吧
Shure: It won't get sun exposure, right?
Shure: 啊快晒到了是吗
Shure: Oh, it's almost exposed to the sun?
Shure: 那费点劲
Shure: That might be a bit tricky.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 哦蛋了我靠
Shure: Oh no, damn it.
Shure: 啊他淡了
Shure: Ah, it's fading.
Shure: 他居然
Shure: He actually
Shure: 完成拍套式的安装了啊
Shure: finished installing the set-up, wow.
Jack: 这么快你说500K我不信啊
Jack: So fast, you said 500K, I don't believe it.
Shure: 那我估计就是他上午的时候
Shure: I guess he must have
Shure: 缓存了一部分了
Shure: cached some of it in the morning.
Lucia: 但是不能喝酒
Lucia: But you can't drink alcohol.
Shure: 没事我我帮你尝
Shure: It's okay, I'll taste it for you.
Shure: 我当你的舌头
Shure: I'll be your tongue.
Lucia: 喝一点点应该没事吧
Lucia: A little bit should be fine, right?
Shure: 最好还是别
Shure: Better not.
Shure: 打疫苗的话还是别
Shure: If you got vaccinated, better not.
Jake:你这个回车敲的挺快
Jake: You type the return key pretty fast.
Shure: 我在敲back
Shure: I'm pressing the back key.
Shure: 嗯嗯
Shure: Uh huh.
Katrina: 还有充电宝吗
Katrina: Do you have a power bank?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 这个上面有纸吗
Shure: Is there any paper on this?
Shure: 嗯嗯嗯
Shure: Uh huh, uh huh, uh huh.
Alice:他什么时候才能把我们的快递送到呢
Alice: When will he deliver our package?
Katrina: 所有的快递都要跟他说他才拿吗
Katrina: Does he need to be told about every package?
Katrina: 还是说他直接报他的尾号
Katrina: Or does he just report his tail number?
Katrina: 直接全部都拿过来
Katrina: And bring everything over directly?
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Alice:你要送吗
Alice: Are you going to deliver it?
Jack: 刘帅改变了主意
Jack: Choiszt changed his mind.
Jack: 他决定先去看
Jack: He decided to check first.
Jack: 因为他觉得档次不如永辉
Jack: Because he thinks it's not as good as Yonghui.
Jake:他他先去看看是什么意思
Jake: What does he mean by checking first?
Jack: 先去看看档次够不够
Jack: Check if the quality is good enough.
Jake:所以我们先去哪儿
Jake: So where are we going first?
Shure: 刘帅才干嘛去了
Shure: What did Choiszt do?
Jake:他在外面坐着啊
Jake: He's sitting outside.
Shure: 啊哈
Shure: Aha.
Shure: 那我们现在干嘛
Shure: So what are we doing now?
Jake:打电话问问呗
Jake: Let's call and ask.
Jake:问问物美你档次够不够啊
Jake: Ask if Wumart thinks you're classy enough.
Shure: 哈哈哈没
Shure: Hahaha, no.
Shure: 没办法京爷就是这个样子的
Shure: There's no way, that's just how King Yee is.
Lucia: 你什么档次也敢出镜
Lucia: What kind of class do you have to dare to appear on camera?
Jack: 京爷
Jack: King Yee
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh
Shure: 我头发怎么又扁下去了呢天呐
Shure: Why does my hair keep getting flat again, oh my god.
Shure: 而且我头发可能是跟心情来的
Shure: And my hair seems to change with my mood.
Shure: 脑袋炸的时候
Shure: When my head is exploding.
Shure: 红线划过深藏轮回的秘密
Shure: The red line hides the secrets of reincarnation.
Shure: 我挥霍运气
Shure: I squander my luck.
Katrina: 真用公费买了一只jellycat
Katrina: I really bought a Jellycat with public funds.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 我说我真用公费买了一只
Katrina: I said I really bought one with public funds.
Katrina: Jelly cat
Katrina: A Jellycat.
Katrina: 我靠这么多快递
Katrina: Wow, so many packages.
Shure: 你买了什么Jelly cat
Shure: What Jellycat did you buy?
Shure: 你用公费买了Jelly cat是吗
Shure: Did you really buy a Jellycat with public funds?
Shure: 然后然后
Shure: And then, and then...
Lucia: 因为它颜色刚好是我计划的颜色一样
Lucia: Because its color matches my planned color.
Shure: 是不是要送给
Shure: Are you going to give it to...
Katrina: 那可不那送给自己的
Katrina: Of course, it's for myself.
Katrina: 不会为了这个
Katrina: Not for this...
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 那第一次啊
Shure: That's the first time...
Shure: 也不是第一
Shure: Or maybe not the first.
Shure: 那你要追人家你就应该主动一点
Shure: If you want to pursue someone, you should be more proactive.
Katrina: 这个叫吸引attract
Katrina: That's called attraction.
Shure: 哎呀你快吸吸吧
Shure: Oh, you should attract them then.
Shure: 你看怎么给他吸的
Shure: Let's see how you attract them.
Shure: 看你是跑的快还是拉的快
Shure: Let's see if you run faster or pull harder.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 道理是这个样子
Shure: That's the way it is.
Shure: 爱情是你独特的味道
Shure: Love is your unique scent.
Shure: 在我地球闪耀
Shure: Shining on my earth.
Shure: 别人都不了只有你知道
Shure: No one else understands, only you know.
Shure: 因为你世界不再单调
Shure: Because you make the world no longer monotonous.
Shure: 你的微笑你明白就很好
Shure: Your smile, it's enough that you understand.
Lucia: 你明天跳吧
Shure: 呵呵不行
Jake:给你搭舞台
Jake:我们去永辉问问有没有舞台
Shure: 好
Shure: 刘老根大舞台
Lucia: 你能学8小时速成的
Lucia: 已经速成的
Lucia: 非常好了
Jake:就是就是
Jake:学出来的吗
Shure: 不是
Shure: 不是跟那没有关系
Shure: 根据歌词solo的
Shure: 情是你独特的味道
Shure: 在我地球闪耀
Shure: 别人都不了
Shure: 只有你知道
Shure: 董小姐
Shure: 你熄灭了烟
Shure: 你说昨晚
Shure: You mean last night
Shure: 还没给钱
Shure: Still haven't paid
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 怎么样是不是很很很董小姐
Shure: How about it, isn't it very very Dong Missy?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 这个问题有价值啊
Lucia: This question is valuable
Lucia: 终于不再是弱智吧的问题了
Lucia: Finally, no more dumb questions
Shure: 呵AI永远理理解不了这些问题
Shure: Haha, AI will never understand these issues
Shure: 哈哈因为他没有这方面的
Shure: Hahaha, because it doesn't have that aspect
Shure: 呵呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hehehe
Jack: 你可以去采数据然后喂给他
Jack: You can go collect data and feed it to it
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Damn
Shure: 好的好的
Shure: Alright, alright
Shure: 那今晚今晚就把女朋友叫过来
Shure: Tonight, I'll call my girlfriend over
Lucia: 哈哈哈别
Lucia: Haha, don't
Shure: 别哈哈哈哈哈哈哈好吗
Shure: No, hahahahaha, okay?
Lucia: 咱屋里一下多了好多人
Lucia: Suddenly, there are so many people in our room
Shure: 好吗好的
Shure: Okay, alright
Shure: 不要再玩我们家大冰的梗了好吗
Shure: Stop playing with our Big Ice joke, okay?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Alright
Shure: 哎天大冰文学
Shure: Hey, the Great Ice Literature.
Alice:大冰打人算群殴吗
Alice: If Da Bing hits someone, is it considered a group fight?
Shure: 哇他可以biu的一下甩出来你看
Shure: Wow, he can flick it out just like that, look.
Shure: 哇太酷了吧
Shure: Wow, that's so cool.
Shure: 没有一个男生能拒绝
Shure: No guy can resist.
Shure: 一个非常直的棍子
Shure: A very straight stick.
Shure: bravo
Shure: Bravo.
Shure: do you know bravo
Shure: Do you know bravo?
Shure: 月里来是新年啊
Shure: New Year is coming.
Shure: 大年初一头一天啊
Shure: The first day of the new year.
Shure: 家家团圆味啊
Shure: Families reunite.
Shure: 咱们什么时候出发呀
Shure: When are we leaving?
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:问什么时候来
Alice: Ask when it's coming.
Alice:送快递
Alice: The delivery.
Jake:我这车还有9分8分钟到
Jake: My car will be here in about 9 to 8 minutes.
Jake:这狗是每个人放门口
Jake: This dog is at everyone's door.
Jake:我们也得做点
Jake: We should do something too.
Jack: 哦这是要干嘛
Jack: Oh, what are we doing?
Alice:我的狗还没啊
Alice: My dog isn't here yet.
Lucia: 耳机还没
Lucia: The earphones aren't here yet.
Lucia: 还要给它夹花花吗
Lucia: Do we still need to put flowers on it?
Alice:不是我那个腿还没剪呢
Alice: No, I haven't trimmed the legs yet.
Lucia: 啊你后面这样
Lucia: Ah, the back like this.
Lucia: 没事没事这样已经很好看了
Lucia: It's okay, it looks good already.
Alice:面条子
Alice: Noodles.
Alice:剪刀在哪啊
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Lucia: 套装勿拆
Lucia: Don't open the set.
Lucia: 因为内有恶犬
Lucia: Because there's a vicious dog inside.
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, it works.
Lucia: 给他写给他写套装勿拆内有恶犬
Lucia: Write on it, "Don't open the set, there's a vicious dog inside."
Jake:剪刀这边有
Jake: There are scissors here.
Alice:这个不太利索
Alice: These aren't very sharp.
Alice:另一个在哪
Alice: Where's the other one?
Lucia: 另一个其实也不太利
Lucia: The other one isn't very sharp either.
Lucia: 比这能好点不
Lucia: Is it better than this?
Jake:菜刀强一点
Jake: A kitchen knife is stronger.
Jake:这有俩菜刀
Jake: There are two kitchen knives here.
Jake:菜刀不能控制方向呀
Jake: You can't control the direction with a kitchen knife.
Jake:你只能直着剪
Jake: You can only cut straight.
Lucia: 给菜刀烫头
Lucia: Give the kitchen knife a perm.
Jake:那
Jake: Well...
Jake:上面有吗
Jake: Is it on top?
Katrina: 问你个问题
Katrina: Let me ask you a question.
Katrina: 北京西站离什刹海远吗
Katrina: Is Beijing West Station far from Shichahai?
Lucia: 北京西什刹海好像在很中间的地方
Lucia: Beijing West and Shichahai seem to be quite central.
Alice:什刹海在中间
Alice: Shichahai is in the center.
Katrina: 什刹海在
Katrina: Shichahai is...
Katrina: 东直门是不是
Katrina: Near Dongzhimen, right?
Lucia: 就是这个这个这个大水
Lucia: It's this big water area...
Lucia: 这个附近应该就是什刹海
Lucia: Nearby should be Shichahai.
Lucia: 我要没记错的话
Lucia: If I remember correctly.
Lucia: 我也有一段时间没来了
Lucia: It's been a while since I last came here.
Jake:走个两环
Jake: Walk two rings.
Jake:跨两环
Jake: Cross two rings.
其他人：哦哦
Others: Oh, oh...
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake: Compared to Tongzhou...
Jake:我们人在北京
Jake: We're in Beijing.
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake: Compared to Tongzhou...
Jake:北京市区
Jake: In the city center.
Jack: 我想我在上海这个地方确实是近
Jack: I think here in Shanghai, it's really close.
Jack: 就可以走走路
Jack: You can just walk.
Lucia: 我觉得我本科都不怎么出学校
Lucia: I feel like I didn't leave campus much during undergrad.
Lucia: 出去学校太累了
Lucia: Leaving campus was too tiring.
Jack: 我是不是要打车
Jack: Should I take a taxi?
Jack: 所以啊
Jack: So, yeah...
Lucia: 你是在紫金宿舍还是在南区
Lucia: Are you at Zijin Dorm or the South Area?
Jack: 南区现在已经是高贵的强基计划
Jack: The South Area is now for the prestigious Qiangji program.
Jack: 新雅和强基
Jack: Xinya and Qiangji.
Lucia: 经管男生
Lucia: Econ boys.
Lucia: 现在是在我
Lucia: Now they're at...
Lucia: 因为我
Lucia: Because I...
Lucia: 我们那会好像他们最早在31号楼
Lucia: Back then, they were in Building 31.
Lucia: 但后来好像搬到了南区
Lucia: But later, they moved to the South Area.
Jack: 现在应该还在紫金吧
Jack: They should still be at Zijin now.
Lucia: 紫金去上课真是把人累死
Lucia: Going to class from Zijin is exhausting.
Jack: 确实所以我从大二开始就不上课
Jack: Right, that's why I stopped going to class from sophomore year.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈excuse me
Lucia: Hahaha, excuse me.
Jake:解决了问题
Jake: Problem solved.
Jake:从根本上解决
Jake: Solve it fundamentally.
Jack: 非常非常好解决
Jack: It's really, really easy to solve.
Jack: 就睡睡到自然醒
Jack: Just sleep until you wake up naturally.
Jack: 然后然后去图书馆
Jack: Then go to the library.
Jack: 是记得去图书馆
Jack: Remember to go to the library.
Jack: 这个南区跟紫金基本一样
Jack: The south district and Zijin are basically the same.
Lucia: 去图书馆我应该不用爬那个好汉堡
Lucia: I shouldn't have to climb that Good Man's Hill to get to the library.
Jake:走吧来
Jake: Let's go, come on.
Lucia: 要命了
Lucia: It's killing me.
Shure: 现在想想我都心有余悸
Shure: Just thinking about it still scares me.
Alice:我的狗放在门口吧
Alice: I'll leave my dog at the door.
Lucia: 我都行
Lucia: I'm good with that.
Shure: 爱情是你独特的味道
Shure: Love is your unique scent.
Shure: 在我眼前
Shure: In front of my eyes.
Shure: 只有你知道
Shure: Only you know.
Shure: 因为你世界不再单调
Shure: Because of you, the world is no longer dull.
Shure: 你的微笑明白就很好
Shure: Your smile makes everything clear.
Shure: 你就像月亮
Shure: You are like the moon.
Shure: 味道
Shure: The scent.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 包都背上了
Katrina: Got my bag packed.
Shure: 我去啊怎么了
Shure: Oh, what's up?
Choiszt: 那多一个人
Choiszt: One more person.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Choiszt: 因为有一个人跟健康主要限坐6个人
Choiszt: Because there's one person, the health limit is 6 people.
Katrina: 哪6个他不去
Katrina: Which 6? He's not going.
Shure: 正好
Shure: Perfect.
Katrina: 12345 OK
Katrina: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, OK.
Shure: 纸狮子
Shure: Paper lion.
Shure: 纸狮子follow me
Shure: Paper lion, follow me.
Shure: 纸狮子
Shure: Paper lion.
Shure: 死柿子
Shure: Dead persimmon.
Lucia: 死柿子
Lucia: Dead persimmon.
Shure: 屎柿子是什么东西
Shure: What's a poop persimmon?
Lucia: 石柿子
Lucia: Rock persimmon.
Shure: 啊石柿子
Shure: Ah, rock persimmon.
Jack: 哎你打车
Jack: Hey, you called a cab?
Jack: 在哪车
Jack: Where's the cab?
Jake:呃打车在这
Jake: Uh, the cab is here.
Jake:开车在那
Jake: Driving is over there.
Shure: 那我跟那边好
Shure: Then I'll go over there.
Shure: 关了
Shure: Turn it off.
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 叱咤风云落日
Shure: Stirring up a storm at sunset.
Shure: 倚身万种凝望
Shure: Gazing with countless emotions.
Shure: 你滚哈哈哈不
Shure: Get lost, hahaha, no.
Shure: 是到时候人
Shure: It's about people by then.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Shure: 你等我把模型跑起来我就跟你们打
Shure: Wait for me to get the model running, then I'll join you guys.
Shure: 好吧今天晚上
Shure: Okay, tonight.
Nicous: 正好你就在那边看着
Nicous: Just keep an eye on it over there.
Shure: 你哎呀
Shure: Oh, come on.
Shure: 不差这一天
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure: 不用没事
Shure: No need, it's fine.
Nicous: 你交一坨屎上去都没事
Nicous: Even if you turn in a pile of crap, it's fine.
Shure: 对你就交一个题目
Shure: Yeah, just turn in a topic.
Shure: 你把题目写了就可以
Shure: Just write the topic, and you're good.
Shure: 呦呦
Shure: Yo yo
Jack: 你这车有BIOS
Jack: Does your car have BIOS?
Shure: 应该也有唉
Shure: It should have it too.
Jack: 他这车BIOS不是很强
Jack: His car's BIOS isn't very strong.
Shure: 啾啾啾突突突突突
Shure: Pew pew pew pew pew
Shure: do do do
Shure: Do do do
Katrina: 可乐拿一个
Katrina: Grab a cola.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 不够
Shure: Not enough.
Katrina: 真的吗不是只有调调酒吗
Katrina: Really? Isn't it just for mixing drinks?
Shure: 大家喝呢
Shure: Everyone's drinking.
Shure: 就是只给来了gas的喝水是吗
Shure: So we only give water to those who came for gas?
Katrina: 喝RIO吧
Katrina: Let's drink RIO.
Katrina: 想喝那个桃子味的
Katrina: I want the peach flavor.
Shure: RIO
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 要不要直接拿一提啊
Katrina: Should we just grab a case?
Shure: 行
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 刚才拿一提就好了
Shure: We should've grabbed a case earlier.
Katrina: 3个这3个味的都好喝
Katrina: All three of these flavors are good.
Shure: 这三个是一样的吧
Shure: Aren't these three the same?
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No.
Shure: 哦不是啊
Shure: Oh, they're not?
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 二锅头你们东北那喝二锅头是吗
Katrina: Erguotou, do you guys drink Erguotou in the Northeast?
Shure: 北京喝二锅头
Shure: In Beijing, we drink Erguotou.
Katrina: 雪花啤酒
Katrina: Snow Beer.
Shure: 这是那种复古包装的雪花啤酒
Shure: This is the retro-packaged Snow Beer.
Shure: 我们家那边的雪花
Shure: It's from my hometown's Snow Beer.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 苏打水要拿吗上次的
Katrina: Should we grab some soda water, like last time?
Shure: 上次拿那还没喝呢
Shure: We still haven't finished the ones from last time.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 没有没喝呢
Shure: No, we haven't drunk them yet.
Katrina: 哎元气森林
Katrina: Oh, Yuanqi Forest.
Katrina: 这下有元气森林了吧
Katrina: They have Yuanqi Forest now.
Shure: 葡萄味的是吧
Shure: The grape flavor, right?
Katrina: 对对对感觉那葡萄汁兑的一般般
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, but the grape juice mix is just so-so.
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 最后喝不了你就带走当奖金了是吧
Shure: In the end, if we can't drink it, we'll just take it home as a bonus, right?
Shure: 拿点易带走
Shure: Take something easy to carry.
Shure: 然后并且很贵的那种
Shure: And something expensive.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 比如说拿两瓶基酒
Shure: Like grab two bottles of base liquor.
Shure: 然后到时候哎
Shure: And then, hey,
Shure: 打包回去吧
Shure: pack it up and take it home.
Katrina: 带回我们宿舍
Katrina: Take it back to our dorm.
Katrina: 我们宿舍有福了
Katrina: Our dorm is gonna be blessed.
Katrina: 有点像那种打猎回来
Katrina: It's kinda like coming back from hunting.
Shure: 孩子们
Shure: Kids,
Katrina: 我回来了
Katrina: I'm back.
Katrina: 订的24号下午2点的票
Katrina: Booked tickets for the 24th at 2 PM.
Shure: 风轻轻吹进了你的心
Shure: The wind gently blows into your heart.
Katrina: 哎杯子打碎了还够吗
Katrina: Hey, if the cup breaks, do we still have enough?
Katrina: 可不可以直接让管家拿
Katrina: Can we just ask the butler to bring some?
Katrina: 就不自己买了
Katrina: So we don't have to buy them ourselves.
Katrina: 反也带不走
Katrina: Can't take them anyway.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: No idea.
Shure: 要不都咱们这次要用一次性的东西吗
Shure: How about we use disposable stuff this time?
Shure: 啊我不想刷了
Shure: Ah, I don't want to wash them.
Shure: 虽然不符合我们这个Eagle life的理念吧
Shure: Even though it doesn't fit with our Eagle life philosophy.
Nicous: 但我们不能
Nicous: But we can't...
Shure: 我们我们能用一次性餐具之类的吗
Shure: Can we use disposable tableware and such?
Jake:不环保不环保
Jake: Not eco-friendly, not eco-friendly.
Shure: 是不符合
Shure: It doesn't fit.
Katrina: 那上次那个杯子打碎几个
Katrina: How many cups broke last time?
Katrina: 那明天人更多了
Katrina: There'll be more people tomorrow.